do your kids like to tease you oh my god
constantly constantly especially i mean
we're we're out of it now but i went
through a phase
with my daughter where i wasn't allowed
to like hum
dance move like i was mortifying her on
every level
um she makes fun of me more than my son
does my son is
he's like he's he's really his humor is
different
but she just like yeah she's always
making fun of me oh my god my daughter's
already doing
that at the age of six so i can't it's
been great foreshadowing for what's to
come
but i i tweeted you a while back and i
said
that you have an honest and captivating
voice um and i asked you to make an
album
so gwyneth how's the album coming along
oh my god this was so nice of you by the
way i meant it by the way
i think that you're a great singer like
in different movies i've seen you
singing
do you love singing i i do i find it
really
um i find it hard like i think there's
a vulnerability that comes out when you
sing that's like
for me it's a bit shocking and i think
that's a good thing and
i i like i like being a backup singer
more like i love
singing harmonies and stuff like that i
would be there's no way i could
make an album or do what you do i feel
like i've been able to hide behind
characters he's saying and things but
if it was just me it would be way too
vulnerable no way
i just like to i appreciate any singer
that it
sounds vulnerable like what you said and
it sounds believable
um but you're an actor so i guess when
you play the characters it's easier like
you said to dip into those feelings or
whatever but
that's what i loved about your voice and
and the few things i've seen you sing in
but
want more fun stuff i thought so check
out these videos floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure